das geht von circa zwei wochen habe ich
folgende nachricht schule bringen klingt
[Musik]
thomas und zwar geht es um folgendes wir
wollen auf den planeten bikini reisen
und wir haben gedacht dass die lebewesen
dort aber unsichtbar sind das einzige
was man sieht sind die bikinis und da
ist die frage ob man das sieht ja
einfach natürlich trotzdem ja gesagt und
zusätzlich will ich noch gefragt habe
ich ein paar von diesen geilen
raumschiff szenen in city 3d nach
stellen könnte und da dachte ich mir
natürlich als erstes alter ultra heftige
raumschiff szenen im weltall mit dass
ich dann festgestellt dass dieses
raumschiff einfach nur aus einem
flachmann und zwei welpe steht und dann
nur so ja also dazu habe ich natürlich
auch ja gesagt wie ich die bikini und
raumschiff szenen umgesetzt habe und wie
die unsichtbaren wie tinnitus aussehen
würden wenn die sichtbare bikini girls
mit unsichtbaren bikinis werden
das sieht in diesem video also wie
gesagt beim raumschiff schaut handelt
sich um einen flachmann mit zwei preisen
das sind so e-zigaretten dinger und dem
ersten teil von ehren mein auftrag
galaxy haben sie das nun wirklich
zusammengeklebt und selber vor einem
greenscreen irgendwie gedreht aber für
den zweiten teil wollte das 3d animiert
habe um dann noch ein paar mehr
perspektiven zu haben die jungs haben ja
schon fertige 3d modelle von einem
flachmann und von den browser geschickt
also muss ich das nur noch zu seinem
raumschiff zusammenstössen ich habe die
modelle noch ein bisschen verändert zum
beispiel habe hier an die seite so
leicht bands daran gemacht und beim
flachmann habe ich vorhin so ein kleines
cockpit reingebracht dann werdet ihr
jetzt zeuge der tiefsee nix whatsapp
konversation überhaupt laserkanonen
alles auch noch ne geile laserkanone
angeschraubt und ein bisschen
rumprobieren wurde am besten sind also
dann hab ich ja noch so ein kleines
zwischenstück zwischen wahlkreis und
flachmann gebracht dass es so ein
bisschen verbunden ist und dann geht es
auch schon an die textur der echte
flachmann im ersten teil hatte seine
liedertexte gehabt deswegen dachte ich
ich mache das für die 3d version auch
und hat dann einfach seine liedertexte
aneinandergereiht und die übergänge so
ein bisschen weich gemacht damit es so
eine große lieder textur ist dann auch
noch das was jetzt in schwarz weiß jetzt
die reflektion web gemacht also alles
was hell ist da wird viel licht
reflektieren bei dem was schwarz ist
dann wird kein licht reflektiert und da
hat man ebenso eine reflektion muster
daran dass es eben noch realer aussieht
hier oben im metall hat man eben diese
leichten kratzer und hier beim leder hat
man eben auch diese leichten reflektion
die halb leder so an sich hat für den
realismus darf natürlich so einen arzt
nicht fehlen die habe ich aus
andere textur ausgeschnitten und dann
farblich so bearbeitet dass es zu
unserem flachmann passt und hab das
einfach immer wiederholt und aneinander
gesteckt und schon haben wir die textur
jetzt sehen wir ja schon mal die ersten
test ran das sieht natürlich noch contra
billig aus aber so habe ich eben schon
mal den eindruck bekommen wie die ganzen
materialien so funktionieren also man
muss halt jedes einzelne material so
einstellen und alt bestimmen wie viel
licht das reflektieren soll und auf
welche art und weise das nicht
respektiert werden soll und so weiter
und so fort bisschen kompliziert man
jetzt nicht zu erklären hier im
photoshop bearbeitet ich gerade eine so
genannte hdi fap es ist quasi ein 360
grad bild was ziemlich viel licht
informationen gespeichert hat mehr als
normales bild und das kann ich jetzt
quasi einmal um unsere 3d szene herum
legen und dann kann das 3d programm
quasi das licht was in diesem bild ist
und die reflektion auf man 3d modell
werfen die vereine richtig calw anders
wenn ich auch richtig gut und auch weil
die sonne halt so rein brennt und man
hier jetzt wird dieses rötliche licht
hat auf eine million im hintergrund ist
und dann die sonne so richtig drauf
scheint bin ich einfach schön
dann habe ich das raumschiff noch
animiert das heißt die bewegung und das
anderer noch animiert die bewegungen der
kamera um das raumschiff herum während
sich das vom schicksal bewegt und dann
kann es auch schon mal zu ändern gehen
was sie wirklich ultra lange einfach
gedacht hat was viele nicht wissen bei
so einem 3d programm kommt nicht direkt
das fertige video raus sondern hier erst
mal nur das raumschiff und eine
transparente hintergrund und zusätzlich
noch verschiedene länder basis also
quasi einmal nur das bild ohne reflexion
dann einmal die tiefen web wo man quasi
so anstellen kann dass die dunklen
bereiche hier scharf sind und die heller
den bereich im hintergrund und schafft
werden dass man so ein bisschen den
tiefenschärfe effekt hat hier das weiß
es in unsere licht fenster hier sieht
man uns ein glanzlicht und das sind
unsere fraktion und diese ganzen ebenen
kann man jetzt eben in abwechselnden
ganzen video vorstellen
und da habe ich verschiedene sachen
gemacht und bewegungsunschärfe noch
drauf gemacht ich habe diese düsen hier
zum leuchten gebracht ich habe noch
tiefenschärfe reingebracht hat den
hintergrund bisschen unscharf gemacht
und so weiter und so fort und das ist
jetzt das fertige video was ich gemacht
habe ihr denkt euch jetzt vielleicht
hinter dem video sei das doch ein
bisschen anders aus und das liegt daran
dass ich quasi dieses raumschiff
zusammengebaut und textur irrt habe aber
es eben aus privaten gründen nicht
geschafft habe alles komplett durch zu
ändern deswegen habe ich das bei dem
modell an marius geschickt und deren hat
es dann mega kurzfristig noch richtig
schnell fertig gekriegt und deswegen
sieht es hier im video auf kanal eben
anders aus als das was ich gemacht
aber ist auch fall spannend wie 2
verlieren die leute hier denselben
schott interpretieren hier marius hat zb
diese urteil in lens flare ich wollte
einfach das grün bei diesem licht
fenster nicht gemacht er gott sei dank
angedacht so viel zum raumschiff jetzt
werfen einen blick auf die bikini girls
wenn ihr jetzt auch in die welt
eintauchen möchte dann kann ich euch mal
schnittkurs empfehlen eine ente mit
hilfe von zwei stunden videomaterial
welches ihr euch wann wo und so oft ihr
wollt angucken könnt das gestalten mit
mir pro link in der beschreibung und
wenn er den coach tom riddle angibt dann
klickt er noch 20 prozent rabatt bis
montag wie die bikinis 10 habe zuerst
mal als getränk das heißt ich habe ein
computer das filmmaterial analysieren
lassen damit der ebenfalls wie sich die
kamera den dreidimensionalen raum bewegt
damit ich da quasi eben danach in 3d
objekte einstellen kann
so sieht es aus wenn das fertig gecheckt
dass ich ziehe immer noch mal dürfen ran
dann will ich nachvollziehen kann ok
passt der track ist damit das noch mal
optisch richtig gut sieht diese kamera
informationen kann ich danach ins 3d
programme reinziehen und habe jetzt hier
quasi in grün diese kamera und hinweis
diese ganzen tracking punkte die mir
auch 3d dargestellt werden was sich
praktischerweise nicht genau wo ich
jetzt ein objekt hin schieben muss damit
es dann auch wirklich da ist wo es im
video ist so und jetzt geht es natürlich
daran unsere bikinis daran zu setzen und
um das möglichst realistisch umzusetzen
habe ich da an 3d modell von einer frau
mit einem bikini und mein gedanke ist es
jetzt quasi eben diese ganze frau zu
animieren und danach war sie die frau
unsichtbar zu machen und dann nur noch
den bikini sichtbar zu lassen auf diese
art und weise kann man einfach viel
realistischere animationen machen weil
ich eben die arme animieren kann und die
beine animieren kann also ein bikini der
den sich ja mal ein bisschen wenn sich
mir an bewegt und so weiter und so fort
und sofern dies einfach im realistischen
hier stelle ich gerade mehr oder weniger
die knochen dieser frau an an denen ich
die dann bewegen kann
also was ich hier gemacht habe weiß ich
auch nicht genau ich möchte mich auf
jeden fall ganz offiziell entschuldigen
dass ihr nie wieder schlafen werden
könnte weil ihr jetzt durch dieses bild
so sehr zerstört sein werdet dass es
einfach komplett weiß also die
anschuldigung
sondern stelle ich hier gerade jetzt
diese frau in unserer szene rein und
passt eben die größe an ihr umfeld an
damit es eben nicht weil es so aussieht
als war zugegebenermaßen schon ein
bisschen komisch die ganze zeit so eine
nackte frau zu animieren also ihr seht
gerade auch dass ich die animation gar
nicht perfekt machen und das muss ja
auch gar nicht sein wenn man sie da
hinterher nicht die arme und die beine
sondern eben nur den bikini sondern
diese szene kommen im hintergrund
natürlich noch diese anderen frauen und
zu jeder frau muss ich quasi auch immer
noch so eine unterlage macht und damit
eben der schatten berechnet werden kann
wenn ich dann auch das firma drauflegen
werde damit so aussieht als würde diese
freude wird auf diesem stuhl liegen auch
dass wir daraus gehören wird in after
first class und da eben dann fertig
gestellt zum beispiel lege ich jetzt
gerade den schatten drauf dann darüber
kommen die bikinis dann muss ich
natürlich aber auch hier den lehnen aus
maskieren weil die läden sollen ja quasi
die bikinis verdecken wenn die davor
kommen und auch diese säule hier zum
beispiel muss natürlich den bikini
verdenken wenn er vorbei geht am
coolsten finde ich persönlich diese
szene gewusst so aus als würde die
kamera diese frau so hinterher gehen
weil natürlich nicht wirklich die kamera
der frau hinterher geht sondern einfach
die kamerabewegung dabei auch nicht dann
die frau so rein gemacht habe als würde
die kamera rente gehen und hier seht ihr
jetzt mal ein lehrer im vergleich vorher
nachher wie quasi diese animationen mit
der frau aussieht und dann quasi
hinterher wie der bikini im schott
aussieht ohne frau und ich finde es
spannend weil hier sieht man einfach so
diesem bikini wieder da so hoch
stolzierte links die über haben wir
diese frau diese komplett betrunken der
hoch stolpert das war auf jeden fall
richtig witziges projekt links mal
schnittkurs ist eine beschreibung und
wenn ihr jetzt fragt was hat der typ der
ganztag getrieben seitdem wir nicht mehr
für die arbeitet nicht aber gerade seit
zwei monaten an einem minecraft server
und dich ganz erklären
ursprünglich wollte ich einfach ein
bisschen minecraft spielen auch so einen
geilen rpg server auf dem man aufbauen
kann aber auch ein bisschen pvp fighten
und auch sachen handeln kann
aber dann habe ich aber keinen gefunden
der das genauso macht wie ich das wäre
hätte dann dachte ich mir okay sie
machst du selbst bist du in zwei tagen
fertig aber dass schon seit zwei monaten
alles klar
beim mittlerweile auch ein paar leute
die mithelfen das richtig geil zu machen
auf dem server soll s klassen liefen
wichtiger und magier mit richtigen
zauber zeug und auch richtig geil der
quests die man von npcs annehmen kann
und natürlich auch mitspieler mit dem
mann handeln
aber natürlich auch bauen könne sollte
jetzt nicht nur um kämpfen und pvp geht
es wohl auch um wirtschaft gehen also
man kann handeln und es gibt auch
dungeons also so race weekend das aber
es sind natürlich kein reines rollen
spielt man kann natürlich auch bauen und
irgendwann sogar seine eigenen staat
gründen
viele andere leute rein ziehen können
wenn ihr euch also für die beta bewerben
möchte und die ersten sein wollte die da
spielen da treibt eine kurze bewerbung
an diese e-mail die bewerbungs regeln
sind in der video beschreibung wer sich
daran nicht hält jedoch prinzipiell
nicht angenommen und wenn ihr nicht auf
dieser reise begleiten möchte dann folgt
mir auf jeden fall mal auf instagram und
lassen wir ein abo da haben sie man
zunächst mal wieder alles gut
[Musik]